trong gia đình trên cả nước kí nhận tầm cộng 2 nước lên nhận độc cạo nhất ngày
vượt giá trị lịch sử, khắp các vùng miền trên cả nước
trong đó có những cột mốt được kí nhận cách này, bụi biệt bà năm
tức là từ năm 2017, của thế tại côn cò tình quan trị
Nhết độ mới kí nhận 3 mệt tạm phải bụn lộ C
sau với cột mốt, 3 mệt phải tạm lộ C và năng 1 chỉ trạm tạm mới bà
Nhìn độc cạo nhất ngày trong gia đuạn của qua là 4-2, 2 độ C
kí nhận ngày hấp lật hằng sau tại tây hiểu tục tình nghẹ ăn
tăng không phải sảo lộ C sau với kí lực cố vui vì nhận cách để mình sảo năm
trong khi đó tổng lượng mưa hồ hết các cột vực trên cả nước
đều phố biến thấp hơn sau với chung bình nhận năm 2019
giây hông cột vực chung dô vùng ngủy bắt bộ và một số nơi
thuộc cột vực chung bộ có tổng lượng mơ cao hơn
từ mấy lắm đến năm 2019
dự báo trong gia đuạn từ ngày 1 tạm bây bụi tạm bây bụi tạm
cột vực bắt bộ và chung bộ tết tục có cả năng xuất hiện nhận ngày năng lắm
tuy nhiên bắt bộ cường độ năng ngọng có xù hình dạm
gước lại, chúng bộ số ngày năng ngọng vẫn có thể cao hơn sau với chung bình nhận năm qua
cân đe phòng năng ngọng gây gắt, còn nơi đặc biệt gây át
trong gia đình này mới lần dễ dọng sẽ tập trung trủ yếu tại cột vực bắt bộ
và các tình từ tháng hóa đến hà tính
cột vực tình bên và năng bộ
xất hiện nhiều ngày có mưa dọng, có ngày có mưa tò
thời gian mưa tập trung vào chiều bình đêm
gia đình này tấp nhìn đối và báo có thể xuất hiện trên biến đông
và ai còn trực tiếp đến đất liển nước ta
từ một cho đến hà cơn
cao hơn sau với chung bình nhận năm